hey uh girlfriend I don't think she's
attracted to me I don't know if anyone
has that problem in their relationship I
was talking to the other day I was like
baby do you think I'm hopped and she was
like yeah you're the sweetest
was that really synonyms but I was like
no do you think I'm sexy she's like wait
very punctual
oh my god that's true a little hurtful
in this context then I was walking away
and I was like I might kill myself but
she's like you had a good run I'm like
that wasn't even a question you're just
bullying me at this point she's real
pretty
she's pretty I'd like to tell her she's
pretty can you tell girls they're pretty
I don't even know anymore I told the
girl I didn't know she was pretty the
other day she got mad at me because I
got I need you to validate me okay I was
just trying to be nice I didn't mean to
imply that you're a mall parking garage
tickets if it makes you feel any better
I only think you're pretty on the
outside now guys didn't get caught
checking out a girl with your girlfriend
not because she sees you but because you
elbow her thinking she's one of your
buddies that's an uncomfortable feeling
I was my girlfriend the park hood am
like hey check out this sug Lee
I hate that woman
thought you were Phil sorry about that
I thought all guys checked out girls
some guys don't I was my friend the
other day he's a straight guy this
beautiful girl walked by I was like
check out that girl he goes why I don't
know I just thought it was the thing we
were doing and we're not doing that I
thought girls are like deer in sunsets
you just point them out if you see one I
guess not I like checking girls out but
I would never I would never cheat on my
girlfriend I want you guys to him a bad
guy I would never cheat on my girlfriend
because we gossip together too much and
I feel like I would just rat myself out
trying to one-up for a possible I'll go
be laying in bed she's like I don't want
to sound mean but Michelle's gained like
eight pounds and I heard her boyfriend
might leave her because of it and I'm
like whoa that is spicy gossip all right
I got one for you you were never gonna
guess who's cheating on you this is huge
why are you crying I haven't even told
you yet you can't cheat though it's very
unhealthy to cheat that's why I keep a
picture of my girlfriend as my iPhone
background picture she thinks it's sweet
but to me it's like a Surgeon General
warning on a pack of cigarette
I mean a girl in the road she's like
take down my number I'm like all right
wait this could kill me with a warning
it's hard to quit but you gotta be
strong you know anyways she's sexy we
have we have sex that's exciting yeah
thank you you're clapping for me or sex
but either way thank you I like uh I
like high heels those are sexy to go I
like high heels during during sex
oh that's thanks for making me feel
creepy there I like shoes in Baker's
preposterous they don't belong in bed
you know that's right it's like a
threesome like you shouldn't be here but
stick around I like what this is also
like a woman naked wearing shoes is like
the sexiest look of all time a man naked
with shoes
not nearly as sexy although we're not
quite able to pull that look off just
yet I don't know the science is behind
it but if I'm naked wearing shoes I look
like a baby that rolled away from his
mother while she was changing him likes
what to grab a wife and I was like no I
hide in the curtain tiny penis flippin
everywhere I think it's a woman naked
wearing shoes it's kind of like she's
like I forgot to get dressed
and a man naked with shoes is like I
forgot to take my medicine I'm having an
episode
they're sexy those shoes are hard to
walk in though I know cuz I've never
tried to walk in the high heels but I
saw her woman fall the other day she was
walking in heels she was it wasn't she
wasn't old it wasn't slippery she wasn't
drunk she was just wearing heels and
then all the sudden she was like ah I
thought she got shot I came running over
I was like this is an epidemic I had to
buy the arms of pulling her I was like
where you hit and she's like it's my
shoe Jesus we gotta get you some do you
get you out of out of those shoes into
bed and then back into those shoes where
it's AIT's been sexy are you guys are
great